i'm a question about your lovely
girlfriend jane who i've met many times
lovely person you guys have been
together for i think 38 years now is
that right you're 38 yeah under nine
years
do you ever think of popping the
question or have you decided
who needs that you know where our
relationship's fine without getting
married
yeah we don't want our families to meet
[Laughter]
really okay that's the best reason yet
i've ever heard for not getting
i should say that lockdown's been a lot
harder for jane
than me because she's a novelist so
she usually gets the house to herself
you know
to work but because i'm home right i
keep hearing i go
shush i'll play with you in a minute let
me just finish this sentence
so it must be like having a toddler home
yes i have the same situation because my
wife uh
is a is a playwright and she'll be
working on
serious theater work in the basement and
i'm just wandering around at starved for
attention
i have no audience and i'm trying to do
schtick and bits for her and she's
she's giving me ritalin now she's giving
this the same medication they give to
hyperactive children
now jane gets up at 5 00 a.m
so she gets two or three hours to write
before i get
up so she has to play with me